("Failed You" by MadReal)
- PureWow.
Thrillist brunch.
Ladies, how's this going?
- Um, it's pretty chill.
It's pretty pure.
Wow.
- It's pure wow.
- Clearly, they've never
been on camera before.
(both laughing)
There's so much
more upside than downside
in taking a risk at a young age.
It's just practical.
It's practical to go
high risk, high reward
in your teens and twenties.
It's just life practical and
I think the reason people don't
is they love their
parents or grandparents
or somebody in
their life that they don't
want to
disappoint by doing the thing
that seems crazy to that elder
and I don't want to sit on
a pedestal and say do that,
but I understand
what's stopping them.
I just want to
challenge people to recognize
that regret is very scary.
Guys, thank you
so much for coming.
Hope you guys have a great week.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
Thanks.
Great job.
And what ends up
happening is you're protecting
your parents'
feelings in your twenties
by doing the thing
you want them to do,
but how it manifests
is in a relationship
in your forties, fifties and
sixties with your parents
that is less healthy
because you start blaming them
for not taking those
jumps and so, I feel like
you can fight with
your parents now or later
and I just think it works out
much better in the upfront.
Great question.
My man, let's clap it up for
this wonderful human being.
You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
We about to
drink some real wine.
Jordan!
Jordan. Did you bring real wine?
I'm like freaking out.
All this bullshit
rosé I've been drinking.
Like this looks real.
How about all three of
you think about this way
for yourselves as well,
knowing a little bit
about all three of you.
It's so much better
when the market comes to you.
Like remember having
conversations with humans
about followers
or just stuff, right?
It's never, it's always
the best when you come here,
and let it come
to you and I think
that's what he has, right?
He's not wavering or
conforming or adjusting, right?
He's doing his thing, and
he'll just basically create
the world to come
to it and be like,
fuck we love this
African kind of vibe.
Instead of like, oh okay,
let me go make hip hop beats.
You know?
- Yep.
- Long game.
Yo.
(glass clinking)
We are very,
very fortunate to have
one of my favorite wine people,
and you guys know how
I feel about ad people,
I hate wine people more.
(group laughter)
So, to penetrate that
wall is very difficult
but in this intimate
setting, we'll taste,
we'll jam, it'll be fun.
Let's take our,
let's put our wine hats on.
Trouty's gonna try to act cool.
Others will act humble,
which we appreciate.
For like 30 years,
the last 30 years,
up until seven to 10 years ago,
the wine business in
America, the consumer
that cared about wine,
not like just bought it
just 'cause they loved
one, but they just drank
eight dollar wine.
Like cared enough about it.
Was completely
dictated by the Wine Spectator,
Robert Parker.
And I mean completely.
Two voices, dictation.
And they didn't
support rosé, and the truth is
most people just believe that
you graduated to red wine
as the real thing,
white wine's the entry
and rosé was White Zinfandel.
What a lot of you
didn't live through,
if you're young enough,
but if you go way back,
White Zinfandel in
the eighties and nineties
was sweet,
pink wine, four bucks,
five bucks a bottle
and it was soda.
So rosé in America got
killed because White Zinfandel
was uniquely American
in the late seventies,
early eighties, early nineties.
Yeah, of course.
So the white, the white.
The White Zinfandel craze in
America killed the rosé market.
To watch rosé now on
the pedestal that it is
in the U.S. is bonkers to me.
To your point, whether it was
Instagram, it was bloggers,
it was other voices that
finally were able to penetrate
and listen, if you
ask me my proudest part
of my chapter in
the wine business,
it was that Wine Library TV
will always be synonymous
as one of those first things to,
when somebody
historians it, Wine Library TV
was one of the
first things to penetrate
those two big pillars
and create another voice,
which then inspired
all the soms to blog
and video blog and
then Instagram and social
and now every sommelier,
every personality,
and there's
just democratization.
- How are you, sir?
- [Gary] I'm excited
about tonight.
Good to see you.
- Hey there, Jordan.
- Jordan, how are you, bro?
- Great to meet ya.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
Yeah, I remember.
I'll be honest with you, I got a
totally different curveball.
Activate brunch,
that's like, and a panel.
Activate dinner
and the thing,
activate late night
with DJs and in the middle,
VaynerMedia B2B.
Steve.
- What up?
- I know you're the
Chief Creative Officer
but I need you to
be quiet for a second.
Jordan.
- Hi!
- How did the wine tasting go?
- The wine tasting
was the most fine and fun
wine tasting of all time.
Thank you for that.
(laughing)
- Ben Benrubi.
- Hey.
- What have you
accomplished at Cannes?
- Throwing 17
events in four days.
- But were they ROI positive?
Did we make
some business happen?
- We did. And we
sold some sponsorships.
- Spot on.
- Yep.
- Matty.
- Yo.
- Have you done
anything productive here?
- Just filmed
for a couple people.
This guy's #AskGaryVee today.
- You didn't film crap for me.
- I'm working on,
look at this guy.
- You're Black Coffee
all the time.
- Black Coffee, Tom Bilyeu
and I got some Ditty
on the screen.
- Respect.
- Big things.
- Alright.
Productive at Cannes.
("Failed You" by MadReal)
- Nobody remembers the loses.
And the reason I say
nobody remembers the loses,
everybody's
playing to the audience.
And that audience may
be your mom, one person,
and everybody plays
to different things.
I think that nobody
remembers, I mean guys,
nobody remembers the loses.
Guys, Shaquille O'Neal,
is Shazam the
first thing you think?
- [Man] You know what, I can
challenge that because people,
if you hit 'em
certain, like Variety,
I bet you you can
all name Lebron's losses.
- Nobody's gonna
remember his losses.
- [Man] I remember,
I know, I mean it.
Like, lost to Dirk in 2006,
- Do you know Jordan's losses?
Go.
- [Man] There were none.
- You're wrong.
No, that's it.
- [Man] No, NBA final losses.
- No, no, no.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's, no no, no
no, that's the thing.
Jordan.
You're young.
How old are you?
- [Man] 30.
- Nobody remembers the losses.
(group laughter)
I'm 41.
- [Man] That 72 game win
season and they lost it.
- No.
Nobody remembers the losses.
Micheal Jordan, when I was in
the prime of my sportsmanship,
junior high and high school.
This is real.
Micheal Jordan, this is
gonna blow your face off.
A loser.
Can't get over the hump.
- You know why?
Couldn't beat the Pistons.
Couldn't beat them.
Couldn't beat the Celtics.
I lived the life.
I lived the... it's crazy.
Right, nobody...
and I promise you,
when it's done,
LeBron and
eight straight finals,
and yes he... you know
what people are gonna say?
LeBron play four
29 hall of famers.
Michael Jordan played three.
Guys, like nobody
remembers the losses.
- You proved a point,
because Jordan lost
eight years in a row
before winning six
championships in a row--
- I know he proved my point.
It's why I'm happy.
(group laughter)
Because he was
ultimately that great.
My thing is this,
more, and another way to say it,
another way to
answer your question,
it all ends up the
right way at the end.
If you are great enough,
because whatever
your excuse is gonna be
to why it didn't happen the
way it was supposed to be,
it means you fucked up.
- [Man 2] Except
for Charles Barkley.
He fucked up.
- Like, at the end of the day,
it is what it is, right?
Like, sports is very different.
You rely on so many people.
It's why boxing, you know--
- [Man] Golf
- Golf, like,
and business, like,
like if I'm as
good as I think I am,
it's all gonna play out.
And if it's not,
it was my not
caring enough about money.
It was my
betting too
much on the long term.
It was things that,
like I'll know what they were
that stopped me.
I've named two of them
right now that would
stop me from being on
the place where I wanna be.
And I'm okay with that, clearly,
because I'm still betting on it.
But my big thing is, it ends
up the way it's supposed to be.
(upbeat music)
So, like, we are like, ugh,
I feel so bad
for everybody here.
(group laughter)
- [Kim] Gary, come here.
Come here.
- [Gary] Oh,
you're gonna show me it?
The Vayner X.
There it is.
So proud of you, Kim.
- Thank you.
- Vayner X.
("Fed Up Pt. 2" by Bazanji)
Hey Siri, play
"Planet of the Apps."
So DRock's kind of like
talking to me now right now,
guys, about like
that Muhammad Ali
comment I said about like
"What was he
thinking in the fight after?"
It's really funny.
He's like, I need
more of that from you,
and like, usually I
don't like to listen to DRock,
but he's not wrong.
Like, one of the
things that I have to
just continue to do is,
you always try to
get better at like,
I need to try harder.
You know, it's so
funny, I don't complain.
You know?
And I don't like
talking about shit
until I have it
fully formulated,
believe it or not,
for as much as I run my mouth.
And so the insight is,
for me to talk
about what I'm thinking,
there's only two
things I'm thinking about,
things that are fucked up,
and thus, since
I don't wanna complain,
I have nothing to say to you,
and things that
I'm thinking about.
Like, how's
this all playing out?
Like, what's
actually happening here,
like the strategy?
But because there are 53% and
41% and 72% clear thoughts,
I don't share them.
I think a lot of
the other pundents,
a lot of the
other people out there
talk about shit that
they don't understand.
Is that Staphon and Britney?
- [DRock] Yeah, probably.
- [Gary] Uh, get back to here.
DRock, stay focused.
I'm allowed to be crazy.
(DRock laughs)
Anyway, I think a lot
of other people talk shit,
run their fucking mouth
when they don't have
complete thoughts, you know?
And so, I'm into sharing more.
I'm into sharing more.
Relax, DRock.
I need to figure out
what I'm comfortable with,
because we all
have comfort zones
and things we're
not comfortable with,
and I don't like to run my mouth
and I don't like to complain.
And I will challenge myself
to continue to think about
giving you the process.
Here's what I'm thinking,
that I'm gonna fucking dominate.
Like it's fucking over.
Like people don't get it
that I'm playing
in 2027, you know?
Like I wish I was a rapper.
If I was a rapper,
I'd be perfect,
because like in a
song format, I can be like,
I'm on '27.
You're stuck in '17, you know?
Like, you know, like
I could do that thing.
I don't, like, for
all the pound chesting,
like, I don't feel comfortable,
like I need to become a rapper.
'Cause...
'Cause that culture, that vibe,
that genre of communication,
there's a good way to
brag to give you insights.
Here's my insight.
Like, I have this figured out.
I'm gonna out-work you.
I'm gonna
out-will everyone of you.
I'm gonna out-will you.
Oh, by the way,
I'm smart and strategic.
I understand what
the fuck's going on.
I know when
there's shifts in culture.
I have great intuition
into consumer behavior.
I understand
voice arbitrage already.
That's why I'm
starting to talk about it now.
I'm gonna win that game.
I'm gonna win the
fucking podcast game.
fucking Alexa's skill game.
I'm gonna fucking win.
Like, that's what's going on.
I'm gonna win,
and the other thing
that's going through my mind is,
you ain't shit mother fucker.
Fuck you, GaryVee,
you fucking,
you think you're gonna win?
You're not gonna win sshit
if you believe for one
second that you're gonna win.
That's what's going
through my mind, DRock.
I'll try better.
(("Failed You" by MadReal)